this is not the view you want when
navigating the sewers canal
a giant container ship wedged from bank
to bank
blocking one of the world's most
important shipping lanes
the 400 meter long ever given got stuck
on tuesday morning
running aground in high winds reportedly
after a power failure on board
a fleet of tugboats has been trying to
refloat the mega ship ever since
while a digger tiny by comparison tries
to extricate her bow
from the eastern bank they would be
trying to remove
anything that is easy to remove but
the location where they're stuck is
actually quite you know it's it's
it's not near a port it is actually
quite a distance away from anything
and this is where um the clear option is
lots and lots of tug boats
and digging around the side 12 of global
trade passes through the canal in egypt
between the red sea and the
mediterranean
goods passing between europe and asia
without having to round africa the
evergivens mishap temporarily closed a
route that's used by
50 large ships every day with the canal
blocked
scores of vessels were left waiting in
maritime traffic jams at either end
this was the picture at 1600 hours gmt
on wednesday
as tankers queued oil prices rose the
blockage another blow to global trade
disrupted by kovid millions of tons of
oil millions of tons of manufactured
goods you know millions of containers
hundreds of thousands of containers are
going through the canal um
in in any given week and so a prolonged
closure would mean that there would be
ships stacking up both in the
mediterranean and in the red sea and
essentially at anchor riding at anchor
waiting for the canal to open the canal
was twice closed by war in the 20th
century
the suez crisis in 1956 and the 1967
arab-israeli war blockades
hastened the development of ever larger
ships experienced navigators
say even in peacetime it is a
challenging route
it's exhausting it's a very long it's a
16 to 19 hour transition
trans transit with a lot of preparations
either end
once you're in the canal it's relatively
straightforward it's a bit like going
through tunnel perhaps but the entrance
and the exit are the problems
it remains unclear if and when the ever
given will be refloated
and able to move every delay a reminder
that turning around a super tanker
really is a slow job paul kelso
sky news